okay guys Doug Walker here and you maybe
watched the bummer view maybe you
haven't but now this is my real of you
my real opinion on Twilight Breaking
Dawn Part 1 and I'm just gonna put it
out there right now this is most likely
going to be a Noah ant Weiler style rant
so it's probably going to be very long
and for the longest time I never
understood how he could speak at such
lengths about something I mean those
videos run like over an hour half the
time and I love them I really love
watching him I love hear in his opinion
get so passionate about it uh and that's
the key word it's a passion about it it
has to be something that really fills
you with something and it's either gonna
be extreme love or extreme hate i
extremely hated this movie god I fucking
hated this movie and here's the thing
okay the you gotta go over what I
thought the other movies of course uh
the first while I know what you're
thinking oh I probably hated those
movies and stuff no I'm free you love
these movies these are beautifully bad
films they are hilarious I love them
okay the first film uh you know where
they meet for the first time pretentious
girl has no problems uh really
over-the-top pale vampire that everybody
in the world could tell is a vampire
except for our main character of course
uh is nothing like a vampire is totally
full of himself totally pretentious
totally just but somehow every girl's
dream because he stares off and looks
you know sad and all we want him uh
absolutely love it
second one uh the vampire boy leaves
home you know thought was fun but we
still got Bella and she's a bitch and
she's insane and she's crazy love it you
get this boy Jacob who's this a werewolf
boy that's some luck picking boys uh and
he's the only decent character that goes
through these movies he is a good boy he
is a good he makes me hard man
is a nice kid he's supportive he makes
sacrifices he is like the perfect guy
and yet somehow this dumbass broad keeps
wanting the vampire so let me absolutely
love it
a third one comes along uh the third one
I discuss with people I think was
actually trying to be a good movie and
maybe had a possibly good director uh
but you know it takes a few shots at
itself you know does he ever wear a
shirt or something like that and some of
the conversations were almost kind of
smart you know but it it's still the
writing it still Stephenie Meyer you
can't save it uh so that was probably
the least bad of the movies and probably
the least funny though it had some good
you know stupid scenes in it really
enjoyable uh so I'm loving these movies
I was hyped friggin hiked to see this
film I could win I saw the midnight
showing alright I I went out there and I
ain't nothing but girls and and
boyfriends that were dragged they just
look so miserable and it's like that's
not for me crowd to see this shit with
sit down the movie begins uh and it's
just like the first one I'm enjoying so
much but the dialogue is horrendous that
the things they're talking about our end
is it's so unrealistic it's so plain to
girls you know emotions and manipulating
it however they want you know just the
teenage impressionable mind
loving it okay now let's talk about some
of the things that this movie wants to
partake in okay well we have marriage
great I love to see Twilight fuck that
up and they do um we have sex vampire
sex vampire teenage human sex and it's
great it's so stupid it's over that
wonderful love it love it love it
abortion ah why like Twilight is going
to talk to us about abortion
Twilight fucking okay let me give you an
idea the way
of this word okay I mean I've just
issued just the fucking word you say
that word I saw those black recently and
he described it as he brought up in his
stand-up he said just saying that word
has clinched everybody's asshole in the
audience up everybody tightens when they
hear that word that's how hot a subject
issue okay I mean it's like you don't
fuck around with this okay or if you're
gonna talk about it you better goddamn
know what you're talking about okay that
the only people that really talk about
it are either people who really know
what they're talking about I put this
way people who should be talking about
or either people who really know what
they're talking about or they're using
it as a joke to show that they don't
know what they're talking about cuz I
make jokes about abortion and I've made
several but the idea is to show that you
know the character is a moron or you're
using it as an analogy you know to press
a button for shock value you know but
but it's you know we're not really going
to talk about it this is Twilight trying
to talk seriously about the issue of
abortion because as I'm not giving
anything away here this is in the
trailers Bala gets pregnant and they
really talk I didn't say really they
just sort of throw this shit at you
about whether or not they should keep it
and in fact it's not even to discuss it
okay that this was my hot-button with
this movie okay this is what I said this
film is sick this is a disgusting sick
despicable movie but I should talk about
it in order okay so I'll just go that's
the only way you can really talk about
I'll try not to give away the ending or
anything like that but okay so it starts
out literally with the wedding and my
favorite scene the whole movie is just
when Jacob sees the invitation to the
wedding just off goes the shirt scrumpet
one second I take my shirt off and love
it um but I mean if he keeps it out of
the rest of the movie if I'm add to the
picnic interests they made the
complaints were finally you know too
much for them but he takes it off in the
first minute so what's what's the point
the point of even wearing anything so
okay so there they're getting married
Edward and Bella Bella even on our
goddamn wedding day never smiles I mean
unbelievable this broad this
unbelievable but you've come to expect
that that's that's fine that's when I
laugh at that's what I enjoy
Edwards there with this really weird
uncomfortable smiling you know whatever
he's got going oh I feel so sorry for
these kids I get the feeling they really
want to do well they want to act well on
stuff but they're not given the right
people to hopefully they can have good
careers after this and they can act well
and stuff like that yeah they're young
come on get in come a break um okay so
uh if they get married uh then we have
Edward uh it takes Bella in the middle
of the wedding just you know just
somewhere secluded corner there um it
goes off he says I have a special
surprise for you and it's Jacob and
Jacob is there and he's smiling it's
like hello Bella and stuff like that
this is a happy moment this is a
positive surprise this was the boy that
I think you kissed in front of Edward
you've openly admitted you have the hots
for and even though you're marrying
Edward you're just like yeah but I still
like him just just throwing it out there
and where it sets this up makes no sense
at all and everybody's happy
fuckity she's got a fight with babbit's
Jake watch every dude right up there
what so that happens um and it makes no
sense okay but then Jacob you know is
there he's on good terms he's like okay
I'm here whatever I'm gonna be the good
supportive boyfriend cuz I've ER you
know whatever nots boyfriend because I'm
the only decent character in this movie
by kick in a clue I should fucking get
over you so you know and Edward I forget
how it comes up but Edward somehow drops
that you know he's gonna get with her
before he turns her into a vampire
confirmed whatever reason I guess you
want to enjoy your time as a human a
little bit more as it
I don't know for whatever reason she
doesn't want be a vampire yet uh and
he's going to make love to her on the
honeymoon Jacobs like are you kid you'll
kill her you'll destroy what are you
nuts what do you blah blah blah and I'm
Kathy really well yeah why is he doing
this then if he's really gonna
physically hurt her and stuff like that
you know because it's what they want is
what they want and I think he's also
concerned about what could come from it
and you know which we'll get into uh but
of course they're in love and that means
you gotta bonk each other's brains out
without protection without protection I
got nothin then they're shocked shocked
when she gets break they're asking is
this possible is this do did you go to
school did you look at the board when
they were doing sex education Regis did
busy looking at each other going on
tortured and tortured I told you i
tortured we should move you know make
out a big look as we're uh uh I'm so
easy I'm getting home okay so they go on
their honeymoon sex is fucking nuts
apparently like he keeps breaking the
but they keep going through beds the
rooms are always destroyed there's
feathers I'm not making this up like the
the pillars are always broken and
there's feathers from the pillows flying
down and stuff like it's like out of a
comedy if this is like a satire of
Twilight and it's in the movie uh yeah
and there's bruises on her and stuff
like that okay so he's like I'm sorry
I'll never never again blah blah blah
and she said no no I like it's okay it's
okay course it's okay he get bruises
from sex you know what it figures
I figured she'd be into that you know
what the stupid little fucked abroad
she's probably good she probably
convinced herself that she's like a
masochist or something no I like to cut
myself
like I like bruises cuz I'm pained I
move so okay so that's going on um and
this is just the typical fun dumb shit
that I love from Twilight I'm loving it
but and everything is just totally
falling the wait just what I wanted to
see from a Twilight movie and then she
gets pregnant and impossible impossible
how is it fucking impossible your head
circe without protection unless there's
something I'm missing unless there's
some aspect I was in the movies that I
just missed like vampires can't get
humans pregnant did was that in there
that I miss that if it's in there they
didn't make that very clear okay um okay
so he gets her pregnant they're going is
this possible is this you know to get
pregnant first of all this can't be the
first time in all the years because ever
has been alive for like centuries and
stuff this can't be the first time that
not just him but any vampire has ever
slept with a human and has not erupted
it it's impossible okay it that knowing
that human race the human animal the
human species it's not fucking pasta
this can't be the first time and it
can't be this you know just benign naive
to it I think they have to know
something but no but they to look up
legends about what happens when a
vampire makes over thinking fucking
legends
how about documents how about a history
how about it doesn't anyone write this
shit down this can not this can't be the
first time it's just can't okay so
that's going on then you got Edward
finds out and she's you know she's
puking she's eating the peanut butter
with the chick or whatever frame
women do and he immediately I mean just
like immediately is like you know oh and
they bring it whatever the lysis panic
woman yeah again should do the paranoia
activity right I just can't believe
they're doing this cliche
the his Bank woman comes in and just
looks at it you know and and he of
course bells like there's one kid dr.
sunny days just like no no I trust her
ways I trust her say you know she knows
the legend Steen okay fucking doctor any
vampire doctors in this world you
created so they go uh Hispanic woman
goes just puts her hand on her stomach
and just says you know the Spanish
equivalent of death and just please
okay so Edward being the ever supportive
Edward looks at Bella it says don't
worry we'll get that abomination out of
you the fuck what did he really just say
that
we're gonna get this abomination out of
you we're we're gonna get this thing he
calls it a thing he keeps calling it it
we're gonna get it out of you but he
looks pissed he's like
get it out of you okay take the right
now blah like like somehow it's her
fault you know it takes two dumbass I'm
sorry again I know you didn't know she
could get pregnant when you make whoopee
but that you're just as big a part of it
it's just as big your creation fucking
idiot so okay so he doesn't even consult
her like you know like she has a choice
in this at all okay like just know we'll
get out don't worry it'll be gone don't
worry we'll destroy that little demon
inside of you
these are words they're using they're
saying demon they're saying you know
little monster there's okay Twilight
gets this really well deserved
you know rap for not being very
empowering to women particularly girls
like teenage girls well yeah that I mean
this goes without saying this is the
first time I really felt that this was
insulting to men okay this is just like
a woman who has no idea and just thinks
of the worst thing a guy could say when
she
pregnant and here's the thing I'm sure
there's some guys out there too I'm sure
there's some horrible guys I really say
this shit this is supposed to be our
main character this is supposed to be
the guy we identify with that we are on
board with this is the guy that she must
have married that all the girls want to
marry Edward she's he says a part of he
sparkles and he's saying this horrible
horrible stuff and he never consulted he
never asked her and I'm sure the
understanding is that well first of all
I mean they think that it's going to
kill her you know that the pregnancy is
going to be too much for her to handle
and that it's gonna destroy her you know
and that that's the reasoning behind I
should make clear but whatever side of
the abortion argument you're on you
fucking talk about it okay you don't
just say dad you really talk about this
shit especially the person that's
carrying the fucking thing and he's just
like no we get it up we're getting a
blob of light it's gone it's dead just
don't even worry about it's just you
know that's it and she of course for
once take a brain cell and saying maybe
Edward isn't right about something uh
you know says no I want to keep it I
want to keep this I want to give birth
to which everyone is no you can't gotta
kill you it's gonna kill you from which
every guy in the audience is going um
and Edward is actually saying if you go
through this if you go through with this
pregnancy I'm not gonna be here I'm just
gonna I can't watch it I just I can't be
around you when you're doing what a
selfish thing to do what is it this is
the one goddamn time that Bella is
actually doing anything resembling a a
human being okay I mean she was the real
monster in these other movies okay the
vampire and the werewolves no no she was
The Creature from the Black Lagoon that
sucked everybody what and and of course
the one time she wants to do something
out
love like legitimate love and
responsibility it's something even
sacrificing her life and stuff like that
everybody's telling her that she's
fucking nuts especially Edward
especially the guy that all the girls
are supposed to have the hots for the
guy that they're supposed to get you
know and I'm sure the earth says it look
he didn't know any better he you know
he's just emotional stuff like that
fuck that shit that is a horrible person
okay especially this young and doing
this stuff and Twilight thinks it has
the ability to talk about this stuff and
it doesn't this is like in the Captain
Planet review when they're gonna talk
about AIDS and I had a little caption I
had all these warnings that one of them
said you're not talented enough you're
not as smart as you think and that was
very much.this do you know your audience
Twilight do you have any idea who your
who's reading your shit and who's
watching your dumbass movies its teenage
girls and here's the thing with the
other movies yeah she's a horrible role
model and these males don't exist but
it's the fact that any girl there'll be
oh I want to be like Belle I just want
no responsibility and I want men to do
everything for me blah blah blah
most girls go through that phase and
most girls are you know reality hits and
then hits them pretty quick and most of
them are too cowardly to go run off to
get married and actually be like well
I'm gonna do it cuz Twilight did it most
are not they're stupid enough but
they're not brave enough to do it
so I always thought the stuff from
Twilight because everyone was saying
it's totally destroying the fabric of
the female mind you know that young
female mind I don't think it is I don't
think it's good for it but I don't think
it's like destroying it I don't think
it's any threat at all because it's
equivalent of like Disney Princesses or
something yeah I don't like the
stereotype but I mean it's it's not
destroying anything I don't think you
know it it's plain to what girls like
and then whatever
possible parents or susana whatever you
know tells them hey you know it's this
is a fairy tale and that's a it's a
fairy tale that's what Twilight really
is it's a horribly written fairy tale
marketed at girl and it's really
successful um but now now you're
throwing this very adult very
complicated issue in that even today
nobody has a clear answer on at all I
mean you know if people say I have a
clear answer this is always right this
is only trying to stuff like that we
don't we really don't and we're still
talking about and we're still trying to
figure it out you think you have the
answers you think you know what's right
Twilight knows what's right when it
comes to abortion Twilight is going to
watcher us unfuckin abortion and and
like I said it's the first time I think
as a male that I felt offended I felt
like you are doing men a disservice okay
it's the first time I've ever felt that
would like anything cuz you know what as
a white male I won't lie we've had it
pretty good okay I'm not gonna act like
you know oh hey the think about us the
poor white it's like no we histories
everything we we've been doing okay and
you know and I'm not gonna complain but
this is the one time I mean this is
where girls are going to watch this
we're gonna take this really serious
issue and we're going to say this is the
stuff you're gonna go through and this
is how you should act and this is how
the men are going to act and this is
what they're going to do to you and this
is what they're gonna tell you and stuff
like that fuck your movie fuck you i I
am so offended by this film I am just
and the fighting the abortion issue is
not even I don't want to say it's like
the main focus it's one of them it's not
the main focus the main focus of course
is the dumbass love triangle or you know
or chick shake up this boy is
his life on the line he's abandoning his
tribe he's abandoning his pack again
he's being the good guy he's really you
know he's really putting shit on the
line he's making sacrifices for this
dumbass girl and she and even half the
time she's like you know I trust you you
know I say things to you I wouldn't say
to Edwards where did you fucking marry
him
he's doing to me oh my god I haven't
gotten this emotional about a film in a
long time I mean at least not at a
negative state um oh this really is my
Transformers to this because I didn't
like transformers too but it it didn't
hurt me like it did so many other people
a lot of people got hurt by transformers
- it was that bad this is mine and I
have no idea if I'm alone on this or
people are just gonna say I'm
over-exaggerating or we're reading it or
something like that I very well could be
ah but I just felt just disgusting
watching this I just really felt
uncomfortable and let me tell you I mean
without giving away anything too much uh
with the issue the abortion issue in
this movie uh knowing the undertones
overtones to a certain religion that you
know that this movie really likes to
play - at least things explained to you
can probably guess where they're gonna
go with it um and the funny thing is
that in another story in another way if
there was talent behind this this could
have been a uniquely touching beautiful
story about a woman who just young woman
who does not want to give up her jaw it
may cost her her life but she made you
know this commitment and she wants to
risk it she wants to take the
responsibility what I mean it's like and
that would bring up the issues well wait
is that right or is it right to say the
mother is a right to save the child in a
bubble and you can really talk about
this but it's not it's Twilight Twilight
they don't know what they're talking
about you
- no you don't know what you're talking
about it's like that guy the glasses a
calm all the people off to do Hamlet
okay we don't go there we know we're not
good enough
it's like Adam Sandler doing a holocaust
movie no he makes dumb movies but he
doesn't make dumb mistakes they're
calculated they know the audience but
they know what they are
Twilight your shit stay - shit stay -
manipulating girls in their little
fairytale land you're bringing this in
abortion you're bringing abortion into
this and my phone is ringing I don't
care I'm not gonna answer it I don't
care who it is at all
no I I have to finish this it's we end
with you know like a c-section that's
that's great again just adding to the
fairytale aspect heavily ever after um
you know and and it's really without
showing too much I think they show quite
a bit for a pg-13 it's really gravely
and they have these sound effects and
and they have the blood flirty hurry go
oh you know and these crunching sound of
it and you know put the knife and you
know from her point of view with them
doing her
and you're really doing this you're
doing this I and I just felt despicable
watching it I just felt dirty watching
this movie I was ashamed to be in that
theater watching this thinking that this
movie had any brains at all I thought it
had some brains you know I thought
because it knew how to manipulate you
know the young female demographic I did
very well I'm very profitable but this
this is a whole new area and if you're
going to talk about you better do your
fucking homework you better have some
idea some idea what you're talking about
and Twilight obviously doesn't and it
shows in this movie and I that's all
just would be a lot so III in terms of
the movie itself and like just the plot
and the stuff that really pissed me off
I I think that's the gist of it except
for the fact that once again Jacob gets
screw and I don't get that I don't gaze
the only decent character throughout
this movie and it keeps you in crap time
repeating myself am okay
so um this is the part where I have to
say who would like shit and who would
not like it cuz let me tell you when the
movie was done there was applause oh the
teenager it understands me don't make me
don't make me pity this demographic
anymore you've already made so tough
showing that you know Twilight that you
respect Twilight and to say yeah that
was good okay
again I this is the real cynical asshole
with me coming out this is going against
what I you know what I say we're you
know movies can be anything to anyone
you know and they can represent
something uh it just for me I think
for my values at my ethics it hurt me so
bad that it just really fueled some
anger in me I mean just a real hatred so
it all nasty I should talk about who
shit like this my let's talk
why did you know a lot of teenage girls
like this move because actually I heard
that a lot of people even fans of the
book didn't like this book apparently uh
which doesn't shock me at all
um but I think the reason they like it
cuz actually I went with someone who
liked it and so yeah I enjoyed Angela
and she she doesn't like bellezza but
you know she she liked her some Jacob
you know I mean she just finds the boys
hot um so and I again I was gonna be
dick I was gonna be like what's wrong
with you you know I I just said I'd be
like that too awesome
would you like about what do I owe it
just I like the werewolves I like the
you know I like the fighting I like do
you know the little drama and hey Bella
died me she didn't smile her wedding
well that was weird but uh yeah I like
seeing you know the fight and I liked
what she had the baby and stuff like
that so my hope with this movie is that
the people who don't like it are
probably gonna not like it for the same
reason they either don't like the other
Twilight movies or the reason I don't
like this Twilight movie the people who
like it my hope is that they just
they're still wrapped up in the fairy
tale aspect and these really sick
disturbing issues are just not going to
hit in that they shouldn't hit uh
because I get this movie doesn't know
what it's talking about uh and I'm
really hoping that just it's flying over
their heads and they're not like yeah
that that got me thinking about abortion
that got me thinking about choices that
got me thinking about you know the the
Twilight choices that is you know and
okay it just as I said before it's not
like abortion shouldn't be talked about
it should and it's not like we should
just always ignore it no we should
acknowledge it we should really confront
this up and we should bring up our
arguments for either side or if you've
even chosen a side or whatever and it
should be discussed or ethically or
physically or legally or whatever I'm
not against that I'm against idiot
talking about it I'm against them
talking about like they know like they
understand like they like they have the
responsibility and the talent to bring
this subject matter to you and that's
it's just they're so they're so full of
themselves on that and they're just I
don't I don't think this stuff is going
to register to the people who like it
which is not to say I would recommend it
to anyone I wouldn't recommend it to a
dog but at the same time I think the
people who do enjoy this it's not going
to hit them straight in the face they're
not going to think about you know
abortions or the issues that they're
trying to bring up so and like I said
this could very well just be me maybe
nobody else is thinking about this I
mean maybe people are just laughing at
it like they laugh at the are Twilight
movies or maybe all the teenage girls
are getting into it just like the gun to
the other ones for the same reasons
isn't the romance though
Oh Edward you know you make mistakes but
I still love you Oh Jacob why don't you
come with Jacob whatever they talk about
um so why is it there if you like the
other Twilight movies there's a much
stronger risk that you won't like this
movie because it does just get so grisly
and so bloody and so unpleasant uh but
maybe I think for a lot of girls like
that just sucks the lore into the drama
the quote-unquote drama um so maybe
you'll like that uh I would just
definitely advise not taking these
issues they're talking about in a sense
that they know what they're talking
about because it is Twilight you're
gonna look back years later and you're
gonna laugh you're gonna really really
you know it's gonna be like when we look
back at Saved by the Bell at the time
was like wow this is high school and not
really always we thought about the high
school it's gonna be the same thing I
mean whether you realize her now and I
wanna be really snobby I'm saying what
you're gonna think um but it's very
likely that would happen I'm not saying
it's now I'm not gonna say you're a
moron if you know if you don't do that
whatever you like you like you have your
own reasons um people wouldn't like it I
think
and do I really have to say people with
penises are not going to like it um
which is not to say everyone with a
vagina will like it but certainly people
in the tween age you know bordering
teenage years with a vagina will most
likely like it um if you don't like to
have a Twilight movies like you really
hate it you're gonna really hate this
one you're gonna really despise it um in
terms of making fun of it there's
definitely stuff to make fun of but like
I said and maybe people will just enjoy
the fact that Twilight is trying to talk
about this and that they look it they
really think they know what they're
talking about isn't this great blah blah
blah I I mean me personally I can't
quite get on board with that I just
think this is such a hot-button topic
and maybe it is like an exploitation
felt even exploitation from view going
in you know you're gonna see if they're
gonna try and push your buttons this
really thinks it's saying something to
you and that it's dealing with an issue
like oh yeah we're gonna be brave enough
to go there it's not bravery it's not
it's bravery is really understanding the
issue before you say a goddamn thing
about it and you don't you do not movie
so okay I've gotten so emotional about
this movie like I said this this really
really pissed me off hopefully from this
review I'm sorry if I really went on a
rant here uh but it just as you can tell
it really hit a button with me and I
just I found it so revolting um and if
you don't if you see something beautiful
in it
I'd love to hear why and I'm not gonna
say you're wrong I'm just I would love
to honestly hear why and how you got
that out of this because I did actually
enjoy talking to the person I went with
I was asking her you know really well
what did you like about it and it was a
very simple response and my guess is
that for most people it's going to be a
simple response so maybe it's not as bad
as I'm making it out but it's just from
an adult standpoint this was you know
really disgusting
gusting film but what do I really think
you're asking I I I think I've gone on
long enough I don't know how long this
is pacer went to my own zone so like I
said this is probably longer than you
expect uh I'm probably gonna encourage
so many people to go see this movie down
because they're like good god I have to
see what the fuck he's talking about
ironically I'm not trying to people that
you know how horrendous it is and people
that they just got to see it so and I'll
say this before I sign out like I said I
may be you know reading too much into it
I'm not denying that maybe nobody would
think of these issues at all maybe I'm
the only wire maybe me and a few other
people and you know we take it really
the heart but if that's what it did for
me and my guess would be even fans at
twilight would have a harder time with
this one because it does get so grisly
and so grim and and bloody and really
tackling just some unpleasant issues in
the way that Twilight handles it so so
there it is man I think I've rambled on
long enough
um might be one of the few times where
the regular review is funnier than the
bum review okay so uh guys take care I
hope you can come to your own decision
whether or not you want to see this
movie thanks for watching later